what's happening how are you
i'm wonderful and um i actually
was reading this with my daughters last
night
and are you serious oh come on
that makes me feel very very good thank
you so much
we'll talk about it in a little bit with
a friend of the show
um who's very special to us but i just i
had to
tell you right away that we were all in
our beds
cozy snugs as bugs and rugs reading your
beautiful
new book that's that's uh
that's something else i really
appreciate that you have no idea how
that makes me feel wow that's good stuff
reading about you
your son is such a priority in your life
and it felt really nice for me to be
reading about your life with him because
i'm in it with my two girls and
you know the world is such a
unique place right now as far as
home school and them not being able to
be around their friends
and you know none of us have much of a
life
outside of the life we have within our
homes
this is true um yeah it's crazy it's
crazy
and uh you know i hate to sound like a
like a
a broken record but uh you know it's
during these times
where i just remind myself you know kind
of how lucky
how lucky i am how lucky we both are you
know even though
the world around us uh seems to be you
know
spinning all different kinds of
directions i do get to spend more time
with him
uh walker he's 11 years old um
and uh you know through through the
books
that that are written and even the the
television program all american we get
to discuss
you know all of these issues together
and in a way
that uh that i'm that i'm where i'm
comfortable and where he's comfortable
you know during these these last uh
these last few months we've been able to
kind of connect
on a lot of you know really important uh
uh subject matter and i'm i'm kind of
grateful for that
something that i was wondering if it's
true because i've already visualized it
and romanticized it in the cutest way
ever that you two have a thing called
night swims
oh yeah yeah that was cute at the
beginning
at the beginning
no i'm like uh do i have to get in the
water too man
but uh yeah yeah we uh we're lucky
enough to have the uh
to have a pool and um and for whatever
reason you know because
we were spending so much time together
in the pandemic um
swimming at night never occurred to us
and uh and then one
one one night he just asked and i said
yes
and we both got in and uh and it was
under the stars and we all of a sudden
we just started
just really kicking it with each other
talking in a in a
i could just tell that he was maturing
and it was a really great moment
um that i don't know you know that we
would have we would have
we would have had you know were we not
right there in that specific
you know area time so uh when he started
opening up
you know inside i was so excited and
just had to pretend you know
like i was a cool dad just listening but
uh but i was so grateful
so so grateful and i continue to be i
really loved hearing that
excellent i'm glad you can appreciate
that i really can
and i appreciate all that you've done
in your life i mean the theater
well you have your theater career is so
impressive um and well thank you
reading about your hesitancy to even go
and meet for rent and then it changed
your life
in many years yeah that was it was crazy
it's crazy
uh i i just i caught my i'm i just
turned 50 and i can i'm saying all this
stuff
that i promised myself i would never say
when i was younger all these cliches
you know i used to hate when people said
uh you know it's a gift that keeps on
giving
well rent rent is literally the gift
that keeps on giving
when someone just asks me you know how
what what it has
meant what it means to me and it's like
it's it's there's it's so much you know
i met my baby
baby mama there it's my the beginning of
my career
and even today you know people are still
we're still getting together and
and kind of moving people you know over
zoom doing zoom
you know charity concerts and whatnot so
it's uh that's that's it's kind of where
it all started
and it's nice to uh you know to know
that it's it's it's continuing you know
what i mean it's uh
we none of us knew you know i mean none
of us knew
um and even walker's mother edina you
know
idina menzel she it's been really great
i love the fact that i was there at the
beginning you know she's
she made history in that show and
continues to make history with with with
her singing and
whatnot and to know that i was right
there i loved sharing that
you know with my son like daddy was
there when mommy first when every when
the world
first listened to her um so that's
that's
that's cool as well wow
[Laughter]
i think all us moms out there just went
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
well give him my number because i'm
swinging and single baby
just messed it up that just messed it up
i just messed it up there just noticed
no no the show must go on um
if you know what i mean uh your current
show
is just phenomenal all-american and i
know
that this project really spoke to you
can you speak to that
sure you know um this show was one of
those
choices for me where i read this script
and and and it really spoke to me and uh
and i just i just said yes and and and
stopped uh
stopped looking at other projects at the
time and as soon as uh as soon as i was
on set
um that's a lie the the first
read-through i knew that this was where
i was supposed to be
you know there were no names on this
project it was a bunch of really
talented excited you know passionate
kids
and a few really great adults but uh
but it was it was it was something
special and uh
and it was one of the you know one of
the one of the few projects that
that i could that were where i'm proud
that the subject matter
has to deal with what's going on today
right now
um and uh as i said before
um i feel lucky i can i can discuss you
know
each episode with with my son you know
some of it's a bit racy but i would much
rather
you know him discuss uh these issues
with me
uh than uh then you know kind of come to
these
conclusions on his own you know with
black lives matter and
racism and sex and you know classism all
this stuff
we deal with on the show uh you know
obviously with the backdrop of football
but uh
but it's uh it's it's a special project
and i've had so many great moments
uh uh with actors and and just with my
son
because of this show and i'm excited for
the future